[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: The typical candidate
for a knee replacement
has osteoarthritis, where
the cartilage in the knee
has worn away.
Knee replacement
surgery restores
the worn areas with an implant.
To help place the
implant properly,
the surgeon can
use an instrument
custom designed for the
patient's damaged anatomy.
A successful knee replacement
depends on its alignment
with the femur and tibia,
the upper and lower leg bones
that connect at the knee.
That's a challenge
because knee implants
are standard, while every
patient's bones are unique.
So starting with an MRI
scan of the patient's knee,
this medical device
company produces
custom-made surgical templates,
plastic devices the surgeon
uses to sculpt the surface
of the patient's bones
to align the knee
implant accurately.
The surgeon no longer has to
visually calculate the bone
cuts on the spot in the
operating room, which takes
more time and is more invasive.
An engineer uses the
MRI scan to create
3D models of the
patient's femur and tibia.
The patient's cartilage has
worn out in between these bones,
causing painful rubbing that
erodes the bone surface.
The implant effectively replaces
the damaged bone and cartilage.
Once each bone model is
ready, another engineer
applies a 3D model of
the correct size implant,
then, following directions
the surgeon has provided,
performs virtual surgery
on the bone model.
This will properly align
the implant to the patient's
specific anatomy and fit
to the angle at which
that particular knee moves.
During this surgery
simulation, the computer
records every bone cut.
The surgeon reviews and approves
the surgical plan only once
before manufacturing begins.
The computer which
recorded the bone cuts
guides a 3D printer to
produce plastic templates
for both the femur and tibia.
The surgeon will use these
to repeat the exact same cuts
in real life.
The 3D printer applies a
layer of powdered plastic,
then, following
the computer model,
solidifies select
areas with the laser.
This process keeps
repeating building
up the shape of these surgical
templates layer by layer.
One printer run produces
personalized templates for
up to 50 patients at a time.
So the laser inscribes
the patient's name
and identification
code on each part.
Once the printing
is done, it's just
a matter of breaking up the
unsolidified powdered plastic.
And fishing out the templates.
They brush off the bulk
of the remaining powder.
The posts on the
bottom are the points
at which pins affix the template
to the bone during surgery.
Next, the templates go
into a tumbler containing
plastic balls and air jets.
As the drum rotates for 20
minutes, the balls knock off,
and the air jets blow off
most of the remaining powder.
The templates exit
the tumbler 90% clean.
They go through two
wash cycles to remove
the last remnants of powder.
Before packaging,
they'll be sterilized.
But first, every
template must pass
a quality control inspection.
Using a laser, a
technician scans
it to make sure
the manufacturing
process produced an exact
match to the patient's bone.
This model shows how the femur
and tibia form the knee joint
and how the surgeon secures
the customized template
onto each of these bones.
Thanks to these
devices, the surgeon
doesn't have to figure out
the bone cuts on the fly
in the operating room.
They're all pre-calculated
by the computer model.
This method eliminates
several steps
required in standard surgery.
The operation takes
less time and requires
half as many instruments
to set up and clean up.
And because the
surgeon no longer
has to drill a hole in the bone
to check the knee implant's
alignment, the
patient experiences
less pain and bleeding
and a smaller chance
of developing complications.
[MUSIC PLAYING]